you can choose not to take this advice
but that'd be foolish
[Music]
hi my name is angel hi I'm Danielle my
name is Natasha I worked in retail and
I'm gonna be giving you all the secrets
tricks and hacks that you need this
holiday season
not only is Christmas Eve shopping very
busy and chaotic but so is the Saturday
prior to Christmas which is sometimes
known as Super Saturday it is the most
chaotic a lot of people will try to do
last-minute sales I know at that
obviously a lot of people work during
the week but the best time to shop is
like Tuesday Wednesday Thursday so now
is Monday and Friday get lumped in with
the weekends but shopping Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and then shopping in
the mornings like right when the mall
opens like 10:00 a.m. is the best time
to shop it's quiet
no one's there the retail workers are in
much better moods and it's very smooth
breezy and the lines are shorter but you
just have to remember that sometimes a
lot of the things that you want are
going to be sold out so please please be
nice to your employee workers and they
will do the best to find what it is that
you're looking for pre-plan I suggest
mapping it out at Walmart they actually
have maps so you can just pre plan go to
where you need to go to instead of going
in circles like a chicken with your head
cut off makes it a lot smoother you'll
get through the day and hit a lot more
stores super important to make a list
and come prepared nothing made me
happier than when someone would come in
and would be like here's a list do you
have these things and I could be like
yeah like let me just go down it makes
it easier for you the person shopping
you prevent yourself from over shopping
or overspending and it makes it easier
for the person working and they can ring
you up and then you can go home and have
a great day and eat some delicious
cookies and drink hot cocoa by the fire
you should really be nice to retail
workers because the second you're rude
to us I'm not helping you with anything
you don't understand this but we have
sometimes special coupons we could give
you we could but the second year rude
I've never heard of a coupon did I go to
school with her I don't know her you're
gonna ask us to check the back for an
item I'm gonna go take my bathroom break
please for the love of God
the back room has nothing there is
nothing back there don't ask them to
look in the back they won't find
anything they're probably just kiddies
I'm here to help you you can just help
me with a smile and just being okay I
suggest going in pairs that way can be
in two places at once so lines are
always long where they're at the
register or in the fitting room so if
you have a partner there say you forget
something they can hold your spot in
line you go grab what you need get right
back and you know what keep the ball
rolling so a lot of people don't realize
this but there's no way we can sell
everything in inventory so usually by
the end of the holiday we have some like
pretty much everything still there it's
just not gonna go to use so we're trying
to get rid of it so we have this like 90
percent off on things if you're smart
and no one does this no one does this
but if you're smart you could wait until
after the holidays and buy your
Christmas or whatever holiday stuff and
then save it until next year and then
you'll have everything a lot of times on
Christmas Day I would get a card from my
mom and it would say like I owe you
whatever was on my list because the best
deals usually happened the day after
Christmas on the 26th I know technically
we wouldn't be opening up something on
like the actual day but this way you can
save a lot of money a lot of times
people are returning items so maybe
something that you wanted that sold out
suddenly magically reappears
and a lot of items that weren't on sale
prior are on sale now so you can get
even better deals and then it's like you
know a fun outing also the day after New
Year's
a lot of big deals on that day no not
the day after the day of New Year's Day
so this next tip is both for the
employee and for the shopper leave the
kids at home
this way the store isn't like a daycare
kids aren't running around your kids not
getting ran over by the crazy shoppers
because you know people go crazy out
there during holiday season so it's just
a win-win for everybody involved
especially me this is not sponsored but
the Amazon app is very convenient what I
do when I'm in the store is have the
Amazon app open at all times and then I
cross check prices if this says $60 and
this says $40 I have an Amazon Prime
account I'm gonna order my stuff
[Music]
okay so Black Friday shopping a lot of
times the stores will do the same exact
deal that they do on Black Friday
throughout the rest of the week
sometimes even all the way up until
Christmas unless there's like a hot item
that you know is gonna get sold out you
should just wait until the whole weekend
has passed and my final tip for you if
you're anything like me I hate shopping
period just shop on line guys I promise
to you they're the exact same deals
sometimes they're even better deals
unless you're just like one of those
that really like to be in the mix and
shop online do Cyber Monday I per
Monday's low-key better than everything
majority of the time cyber monday deals
are way better great deals you'll get
through it I think most importantly just
be super kind to the retail workers they
really do know what is in the store
what's in stock what they have so if you
really don't know what to shop for ask
them they will know holiday shopping can
be stressful but just try to make it fun
but also be very mindful that that's not
all that the holidays are for it's you
know showing loved ones that you
appreciate them and spending time with
the family it's not all about the gifts
guys you can choose not to take this
advice but that be foolish
take my advice skip holiday shopping
stay home Amazon
[Music]